Speaker 1: I can't think of anything that it would
feel better to be completely wrong about. Then,
criminal charges and Donald Trump. The news
is that Donald Trump's lawyers now seem
increasingly convinced this guy is getting charged
criminally and they are now preemptively planning
how to handle criminal charges against the former
president, Donald Trump. Now, until that happens,
it's nothing, okay. And it hasn't happened yet.
I've been saying all along Trump's not getting
charged and I would love to be wrong. I won't eat
my microphone. I need the microphone for the show,
but I would love to be wrong about it. Very
interesting new article from Rolling Stone.
Trump's lawyers are preparing legal defenses
against criminal charges. According to internal
communications reviewed by Rolling Stone, Trump's
team is quietly planning for criminal charges
as they wait for the Justice Department to make
its move. This would be absolutely historic.
It would be an historic day, in
fact. Donald Trump's lawyers are
preemptively preparing a legal defense against
criminal charges from the Justice Department.
As the former president's lawyers are increasingly
anxious, their client will be prosecuted for his
role in the attempt to overturn the 2020 election.
Members of Trump's legal team have already started
to brainstorm strategy and potential defenses,
according to three people familiar with the matter
and written communications reviewed by Rolling
Stone understand that Rolling Stone has reviewed
written communications, presumably emails and
or text messages where it is being discussed
by Trump's lawyers how they would handle such
criminal charges. Trump himself has been briefed
on potential legal defenses on at least two
occasions this summer. That effort intensified
after Trump White House former Trump White
House aide Kassidy Hutchinson's June testimony
before the House committee investigating January
6th, quote, Members of the Trump legal team
are quietly preparing in the event charges are
brought. It would be career and career malpractise
not to do so. Do the former president's
attorneys believe everything Cassidy said? No.
Do they think the Department of Justice would
be wise to charge him? No. But we've gotten to
a point where if you don't think criminal charges
are at least somewhat likely, you are not serving
the former president's best interests.
Folks, I know I've been saying all along,
Trump's not getting charged. I hope I'm wrong.
I will come and throw my eye with tears in my
eyes. I will come to all of you and say,
sirs and M&Ms. I was wrong and I love it
now. What is a preview of Trump's legal defense?
Is it going to be made up significantly of
presidential immunity? That's it. We don't know.
But it is certainly plausible that Trump will try
the immunity defense. Legal experts think it's
unlikely the Supreme Court would allow that.
Another possibility would be some version of what
sometimes referred to as the Oliver North defense.
The idea there is you really can't try Trump for
any of this stuff because you can't actually get
a jury because everyone witnessed the crime, the
the things that he is potentially going to be
charged with. If he's charged, we're operating in
a world where he gets charged. The things he would
be charged with are things that he did at least
partially in public. So how do you get a jury
that will really be able to restrict its judgment
to just what is presented during a trial? Now,
I've actually talked about another problem
when it comes to such charges. How do you
even find a jury aside from people that saw
the alleged crimes in public? How do you find a
jury with no preconceived opinion based on their
beliefs about Trump? And what I mean by that is
with some crimes, if the crime takes
place in Kansas City, Missouri, you say,
well, let's move it to the next county over
where people aren't familiar with the crime.
But this is a national really a global situation
that relates to Trump's attempt to steal the
election. And also, most people have a very
strong opinion of Trump. I mean, listen,
I if I were to be called to be on this jury, I
can't imagine they would want me on there since
they've been doing years of commentary about
exactly what the trial would be about. But
I'll be totally upfront with you at this point,
I don't think it would be possible for me to put
aside my opinions about Trump and the case and
say only based on what's in maybe in the trial,
they don't have the clip of Trump asking for
11,780 votes. Am I really going to be able to
pretend that that didn't happen?
Speaker 4: I need.
Speaker 3: 11,000 votes. Give me a break.
Speaker 1: I don't know. So. So another
question is, how do you actually get
a get a jury? Let's wait. And. See.
But the fact that Trump's lawyers are now
preparing for criminal charges certainly
suggestive of the fact that they are more
likely than at any previous point to becoming